[Music]
it has been a week with air punch Pro so
I just wanted to do a pilot video a lot
of you guys have so many questions do I
like them what do I think how does it
hold up in everyday use and so far it's
been pretty good my only main concern
with them is again a lot of these in-ear
things do not work with my ears so I
ended up switching to the smallest
little settings on these silicone ear
tips and since I did that they have been
working out really great initially I
thought I had to go to the larger
version because they got falling out of
my ears and then I went to the medium
and that one worked pretty well and then
when I switched to the smallest version
I was like why didn't I just do that
from the beginning because it ended up
working out great so the sound quality
has been awesome
I haven't yet been on another flight but
I will be heading out pretty soon here
to do some traveling so the battery life
has been pretty good so far you will get
about 4 and 1/2 hours when you have
noise cancellation on and honestly
that's really not that bad I mean I was
thinking that ok for 1/2 hours that's
not enough time for me to get from the
west coast to the east coast
but with a 5 minute charge time that
will give you an extra hour so when you
think about it in that sense that's
enough time for me to get up go wait in
line and go to the bathroom and come
back and I will have over an hour of
charge added to my air pods and I travel
so much and I've really never had an
issue where my ear pods have died on
it's like because of that quick charge
that makes such a huge difference
one of the things that I realized I
didn't even touch on very much is the
sound quality of these in my initial
review well whatever reason I just kept
saying that they sounded great and it's
really hard to describe don't really
know how to explain to you guys what I'm
hearing I just know that it sounds good
it sounds way better than the previous
version of the air pods it sounds better
than most in your earbuds that I've
compared it to and right now is such a
weird time because everyone is releasing
wireless earbuds and it's gonna be
really hard to compete with the air pods
because of how compact they are how they
sync directly to your phone
you can use these with Android because
they are glued to this obviously you
won't have the same functionality that
you'll have with these as you do with
iOS so they took me a little bit of
getting used to though was this little
button that answer calls to to skip
three to go back and a long hold will
switch this from the various modes
transparency to noise cancellation and
the noise cancellation it's pretty
awesome I was kind of surprised because
these are so small the amount of noise
cancellation that you do get is pretty
shocking and since these are so tiny I
think it's gonna be kind of shocking for
a lot of people you're like me how is
this happening
another thing a lot of noise cancelling
headphones for me I do have a lot of
weird inner ear issues so sometimes that
noise cancellation give me like this
really weird pressure especially these
types of inner ear things I mentioned
this also in my initial review but this
has a little air vents that allow
airflow to flow through the air pod and
with that I feel like that alleviates a
lot of that weird pressure that you tend
to get from these types of in your
earbuds when I first got the original
air pods
I made a bunch of videos about it and
the weird thing was you did not fit in
my ears probably for the first few
months like I just kept putting them in
I would still wear that but eventually I
think my ears they molded like I adapted
to the technology so now these honestly
work so well they stay in my ears I've
also found and I know I can't be alone a
lot of these types of earbuds if I put
them in my ears and I smile it does like
a weird little scrunch and they end up
falling out so when I did first get
these I don't know what like if they
would fall out when I would smile don't
look at me I am achieving up a storm and
the air pods have conformed to my body
or the way I have conformed to the air
pods here we go let's let's do the smile
test something oh I've got the noise
cancellation on oh gosh it's so it's so
shocking so when you go in this is in
the volume controls you'll see that you
have the noise cancellation you can turn
it off and if you do turn it off you'll
just sort of hear the outs
noises so it just basically sounds like
you have air pods in but with the
transparency I love the transparency
thing the only issue that I have found
is because I have long hair
this has microphones on the outside that
is allowing you to hear things around
you so if you have long hair your hair
will sort of rub on the outer
microphones so that sound will also be
enhanced inside of your head so it's
like you can hear the hair on your head
it's a weird feeling so kind of sounds
like just if I was rubbing the
microphone that I'm wearing so kind of
like but for you guys and gals that have
short hair or if you pull your hair back
you won't have that problem
[Music]
so another thing that I'm really excited
about the air pods is I bought a
bluetooth dongle my Nintendo switch and
I did a review on them to switch when I
first came out with me to switch light
and they tend to actually stop me even
to check out so it's a hidden Nintendo
and I've been absolutely loving it since
I made this video Luigi's Mansion just
came out storing Halloween and this game
is so much fun I know this is an air
pods video but this little dongle allows
me to use Bluetooth so now I don't have
to have wired headphones to them as much
although I do look a little silly with
just hanging out here but at this point
in my life I don't really can't really
look like so judge me her oh you will
and this is the internet so secondly
something that you guys do
I got a muffin no it's bacon
oh wow
I can hear myself chewing because I have
the transparency mode on
[Music]
nice movie are they worth the upgrade in
price
I definitely think they are mostly for
that noise cancellation just to be able
to shut out the outside world and to
have better sound quality I think it's
worth it it is a big price difference
and if you don't want to sludge and get
the pro it doesn't even matter because
the regular air pods are still so
incredible like I haven't found anything
that I have liked more the form factor
of the case even the bigger case for me
doesn't really make that much of a
difference because it's really not that
much bigger I don't think I'd ever saw
the insta 360 video that I did they have
a little insta 360 to go and it has a
small little case just very similar to
this and for a while I was carrying the
insta 36 to go everywhere I went
so I'd reach in my bag and I would
always grab my hands to 360 go camera
instead of my air pods so the size of
this case is a lot more designed to like
be into 360 go case as a side note I
freaking love that little camera it's
amazing so I guess after a week of using
the air pods Pro I still love them I
actually love them more after using them
for a week it connects very quickly to
my phone to my laptop so making that
switch from device device is so seamless
so even now when I'm traveling I usually
do have a backup pair of headphones so
now I'll be able to take my air Potts
Pro and my regular version as well just
in case you never know when you might
lose a pair of headphones and for me
basically like I rely on this because
I'm always on my phone and always
editing and basically my entire life
exists on the go as crazy as it is I
need to be able to just have everything
with me and have it accessible and so
far the earpods Pro I'm a huge fan I
would love to hear what you guys think
did you get them what are your initial
first impressions if you do have them I
would love to hear from you guys in the
comments below and I have a see you guys
in the next video don't forget to
subscribe and like this video if you
liked it and I will be doing a little
giveaway soon of some Apple goodies for
the holidays so be on the lookout for
that I'll see you later
bike
[Music]
Oh